nourris on va démarrer avec enora et
nora qui va aider voilà qui va aider la
liste bretonne viva et des u17
exactement cet automne donc sur le
trampo des gago allez-y n'aura alors s
est bien on attendait la fin de vie
chère entamé chéri d'amour prévu c'était
trop beau ce que je peux revoir si vous
avez prévu d'abord rigolade à boire et
chacun on en vienne à lorsque je tiens
surtout à lorsqu'il faut pas le faire et
n'aura que j'allais prendre le casque
allez-y donc et doha vous allez avoir
trente secondes pour éclater le maximum
de ballon pascal n'a et n'aura il ya des
belles choses ya des moins belles choses
à chaque ballon crevé ans est sombre
pour l'unicef serrières alors ne
regardez mais finissait c'est bon on y
voit là et gardent exactement attention
ces parties cop
allez on y va
bakou
[Applaudissements]
maintenant il reste à 10 secondes
braga
[Musique]
il ya deux personnes qui se mettent là
et là parce que on a failli la perdre y
aurait pas qu'on perde nourrit également
déblayer le terrain les forces vives de
tout ça on passe de venir au tour aller
non mais c'est bon je nettoie ses mots
regarder
[Applaudissements]
c'est un grand talent et déjà les bras
tu fais un mail de plus va pas les
mettre à l'arrêt moteur à parce que
sinon il lui arriverait donc au nombril
mais n'aura souri quand la police froid
sur l'europe
alors est ce que l'on dit est ce que
l'on arrive à faire mieux
l'oryx chaque ballon crevé donc c'est
sûr euros pour l'unicef
il ya de tout il ya de tout allez-y la
même attaque ici à temps elle va
attendre et on arrête toi va tout péter
[Applaudissements]
tu sors attention allez ma chérie
m
[Applaudissements]
donc éclater cinq ballons ou huit
ballons cinq ballons et bien écoutez je
rajoute les deux ballons et on donne
1000 euros pour l'unicef merci non non
attendez remettez-le h20 mais terme été
foutu de ma gueule à l'égard comment
vous allez me dis mille euros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gars on vient de tirer une carte
chance y'a marqué erreur de la banque en
votre faveur
on donne 10 millions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]